hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the topics that lactancius is
exploring in chapter 17 through 20 of
his work on the anger of God is what we
could call a complex tension between God
as being merciful as as feeling
pity or compassion towards human beings
and pardoning them overlooking their
offenses on the one hand and also
judging them strictly punishing them
being angry being moved by anger to
punish them on the other hand how are
these compatible and this is a really
central question in a lot of Christian
theology it's going to be considered by
many other later thinkers but you see
lot tonsi has kind of arranging this
within the general schema of his
understanding and in chapter 17 he is
going to bring up this no notion of
Eternal or Divine Law and he's going to
say it doesn't really make sense for God
to be you know completely detached and
not care about the violations of the law
or even despising the Divine Law those
who who flout it or who denigrated or
stuff like that now that doesn't mean
that he's going to punish immediately
but God is going to be as he says
rightly moved to feeling anger against
those who are in fact bad or Wicked the
malos he thinks that this is a
legitimate affection or emotion for God
Phil and we see that lactancius is very
aware of the criticisms that can be and
very often are brought up against a
punishing God right often mistakenly
cast as the god of the Old Testament
versus the god of the the New Testament
it's it's not so cut and dry and simple
as that but the critics will charge
God or the people who are you know
portraying God in this way with
bitterness
it's interesting too that it's not a
mother tudas right but
sort of you know puckering and sourness
right or with malice malitzia right or
with engaging in injury against those
people that God is punishing right
nokare is the the verb there and
lactancia says well that's a mistaken
point of view why is it well you know if
the law was actually wrong and injurious
well then that wouldn't be a problem but
he says that
um it follows you know if we think that
this law is injurious that we have
injurious laws which enact punishment
for offenders and injurious judges who
inflict Capital punishments on those
convicted of crime but if the law is
just which Awards to the train
transgress or his due and if the judge
is called upright and good when he
punishes crimes why is he called that
lactancius is putting forth a general
principle here what is the person who's
punishing crimes do guarding the good
right preserving the the good in
existence and opposing the evil if you
really think that something is evil
don't turn a blind eye to it actually
protect those who are going to be
damaged by it he says that it follows
that God when he opposes the evil is not
injurious but he himself is injurious
who either injures an innocent person or
now notice this
spares an injurious person that he may
injure many letting offenders off the
hook out of a you know sense of like
let's be compassionate let's be merciful
let's be understanding that sets up a
bad dynamic in which they're going to do
more of that and you're actually being
bad to the Good by by doing that and
here is where he he introduces this
notion or this analogy rather of
something like a household being the
entire world he says I would gladly ask
from those who represent God as
immovable if anyone had a property a
house a household of slaves and a slaves
despising the forbearance of their
Master should attack all things and take
the enjoyment of his Goods if his
household should honor them well the
master was despised by Holland deserted
could he be a wise person who would not
Avenge the insults but permit those over
whom he had power to have the enjoyment
of of his property right and he says no
no this is this is kind of crazy this is
a foolish way of looking at things and
so he goes on and he says that to be
angry is the part of Reason thus faults
are removed licentiousness is curbed
this is plainly in accordance with
Justice and wisdom so that's chapter 17.
so now we've got you know God should
punish right
chapter 18
we see this again
um being discussed and a few new things
being introduced here so being unmoved
by not having the emotion of anger not
having a reaction you could say or even
approving people doing the wrong things
this is a sort of lenitas or leniency
that is actually unjust and not good so
um you know lactancius is talking about
God being a judge here and then he comes
back to this question of the household
he says that we when an offense is
committed by our household at home
whether we see it or perceive it must be
indignant indignar right which is not
quite the same thing as era anger but
it's on the same Spectrum the very side
of a sin is Unbecoming uh the one who is
unmoved or approves of false which which
is more disgraceful in unjust or
avoids the trouble of approving them
right he says that this is unseasonable
leniency that grants pardon more
frequently than is necessary so now
notice you should actually pardon
sometimes but you got to be wise just
prudent in pardoning right and so he
goes on and he actually says you know
restraining sins restraining anger in
the face of sins wrongdoing deliberately
is actually vicious vitiosa it's not
virtuous it's a sign of going wrong
thinking I don't want to deal with this
and you're leaving other people in the
Lurch as a result so he talks about this
guy architos of tarantum who's praised
when he comes home and finds everything
ruined in his estate and he rebukes the
fault of the bailiff the person who's in
charge of things we sometimes call
there's a steward right or the manager
and he says I would have beaten you to
death if I had not been angry and so a
lot of people bring this up and they're
like see that's the way you should
behave when you're angry don't punish
because you're going to do the wrong
thing and you know this is a kind of
common place in the literature on anger
what is uh loctanius tell us about this
he says that they don't see how
foolishly he spoke and he acted if as
Plato says no prudent person punishes
because there's an offense but to
prevent the occurrence of an offense
right what we call a deterrence or you
know other sort of future oriented view
on punishment he says it's evident how
evil an example this wise man put forth
why because if slaves perceive their
Master uses violence when he's not angry
and abstains from violence when he is
angry what are they going to do they're
not going to commit small offenses
they're going to commit big offenses
because they know the big offenses will
get him angry and then they won't get
punished at all whereas the little
things ah they they might get punished
so this is actually encouraging
wrongdoing on the part of those within
one's household
he goes on and he says I would praise
him if when he was enraged he had given
space to his anger that the excitement
of his mind might calm down through the
interval of time and his chastisement
might be confined within moderate limits
so on account of the magnitude of the
anger punishment ought not have been
inflicted but ought to have been delayed
lest that inflict upon the offender pain
greater than his just or occasion an
outburst of Fury in The Punisher so he's
saying you don't have to punish
immediately right
but you should actually feel something
about the wrongdoing that these people
are doing and uh you know he's saying
that this is a mistaken uh example that
were being put put in front of us right
he says that architis would have been
deserving of Praise if when he'd been
enraged against any citizen or equal who
injured him he had curbed himself and by
forbearance mitigated the impetuosity of
his Fury this self-restraint is glorious
lactancia says for those who are under
you who you are in charge of you know
ordering uh this is not something good
and we can ask well what's the case with
God are we like on the same level with
God I mean sometimes we imagine that we
are and we're like well God should have
done this God should have done that or
you know and God is going to do what God
is going to do because God is a higher
being at least for LA Times Yes
um in chapter 19 towards the end he is
going to bring up that God can in fact
pardon or Overlook faults sins all of
these sorts of things this goes beyond
just waiting to inflict punishment this
is saying God can actually decide not to
inflict punishment that ought to be
inflicted and why is this the case so he
says
um
the judge cannot pardon offense as the
human judge because he's subject to the
will of another right but God can pardon
because he is himself the arbitrator and
the judge of his own law it's his own
law that he's administering and so when
he's laid down this he didn't deprive
himself of the power but he has the as
lactances is going to say Liberty
licensia or you could say authorization
coming from himself of overlooking or
pardoning uh igno scandi which is a
gerund there he'll also use ignosuke
which literally means to not know about
and you can say well how does God and
omniscient being not know about
something well God chooses not to you
know focus on that to overlook the ways
in which we've screwed up but then
finally we get to chapter 20 which is
actually called of offenses and the
mercy the Miser Cordia of God
and it begins if he's able to Pardon he
is therefore also to be angry and then
you know this raises an interesting
question and we could say we can wire
this if God can be angry and punish and
care and pardon
why are things the way they are
why does the world look to be you know
kind of screwed up this is an age-old
problem as well that he asks uh someone
will say does it often occur that they
who sin are prosperous and they who live
piously are wretched because fugitives
and disinherited persons live without
restraint and those who are under the
discipline of a father or Master them a
more strict or Frugal manner you know
why is the world this messed up thing
where it seems like goodness isn't
rewarded and evil isn't actually
punished and so he has a couple
responses to this one is well you know
it's about taking the virtuous and
confirming them in their virtue
interestingly locked hansius thinks that
we actually do need this messed up world
in order to develop virtue uh in order
to choose the good and reject the evil
right so there's an argument there he
talks about virtue being proved
and fixed made constants right by evils
by bad things Mala and he uses this in
the plural and then he says vices on the
other hand uh are you know approved and
and uh fixed by what by Pleasure
voluptatum in the singular but it could
be lots of different Pleasures so you
know God is giving us the space
to develop ourselves he's not punishing
he's not restraining the evildoers right
away and you know then he provides
another longer discussion that provides
you know one more argument you could say
and there's really two sides to this one
is as he points out
um
somebody says if God is angry he ought
to Afflicted Vengeance at once and
punished everyone according to their
dessert so you know if God really is
angry why aren't we seeing the the
results of that right now and
um lactancia says if God did this no one
would survive
everybody's screwing up in some way
right and if God was going to apply the
law very very strictly and not you know
pardon show Mercy at any time we'd all
be screwed there wouldn't be any human
race left right he says
um
uh one reason for destroying the human
race might have been a just one that
people despising the Living God pay
honor to Earthly and frail images and
even with that God doesn't destroy
everything right so you know don't ask
for that that would be kind of
ridiculous again he says to such an
extent is the Frailty of the flesh with
which we're clothed liable to sin unless
God we're indulgent to this necessity
too few would live on this account he is
most patient and does in fact restrain
his anger doesn't restrain it in the
sense of not feeling it but
doesn't act on it right away and so this
is where we can talk about patience
patsiencia
which is recognized by Christians as a
virtue one of the virtues right it's
actually the one that's typically
opposed to anger in this case it
functions as a kind of what would we say
modifier of anger so he goes on and he
says on this account he is most patient
for in him there is perfect virtue God
is completely virtuous right not like
our partial virtue and it follows of
necessity that his patience also is
perfect which is also a virtue so God is
showing us in some respect how we ought
to ourselves behave so he's perfect with
human beings and this creates
opportunities
opportunities that we see human beings
actually taking what are uh the examples
here
how many men from having been Sinners
have afterward become righteous from
being injurious have become good from
being Wicked have become temperate how
many were in early life base and
condemned by the Judgment of all
afterwards turned out praiseworthy this
could not happen if punishment followed
every offense so by allowing punishment
not to happen right now God provides a
space in which people can be like Oh I'm
screwing up man I need to fix my life
maybe make some amends for the bad stuff
I did back here and certainly changed my
way of being in the future which allows
people to be changed to go from being
bad to good and so part of the pardoning
it's not like a blanket oh do whatever
you want it's more like hey I'm not
going to punish you because I want to
see you doing better for yourself and
for all the other people that are stuck
be being here on this Earth with you and
so there's the possibility of mercy of
Pardon of forgiveness even and that
allows the Divine anger and Punishment
not to be inflicted which will then
allows for greater good so this is
lockedancius's point of view on this
this rather complicated set of issues